uh Sunny has a cycle every 11 years the
magnetic field of the Sun goes from
being minimum to maximum and so we are
in the rising phase of the solar cycle
right now the interesting part is that
this is the first time in the history of
humankind we have as many satellites in
space and we are launching like think of
Starlings every other month we are
launching satellites these are all
vulnerable to what happens on the Sun so
these charged particles interact with
the electronics of the machines and you
there's no telling what effect it will
have that's right so that's why when you
know it's coming we sort of send a
warning to operators to turn this off
but it's not just Electronics
foreign
[Music]